احنا اليوم لما نيجي نتكلم مع الرئيس
في اييي الايام الماضيه
منتخب البحرين فاز على دوله الكويت منتخب
دوله الكويت في البصره مع الاسف الشديد
يعني بدل ما تصرح طيران الخليج النهائيه
بتفتح خط علق المباشر الى البصره او الى
النجف لانها قريبه تقوم تخفض بنسبه 25%
تخفيض الى بعض الدول وخلنا نسميها
مسمياتها وهي كيان الصهيوني
25% وما حد يروح على الطيران يعني انت لما
جيت تتكلم تقول طيران الخليج يسير رحلات
الى الكيان الصهيوني اا من غير مردود من
غير ركاب انا بعرف ليش التعبد من طيران
الخليج او اداره طيران الخليج بفتح هذا
الخط اللي احنا نعتبرك شعب البحرين بكل
طوافه انه هو من الخطوط الخاص
ظافر الى الكيان الغاصب وهو وهو كيان مجرم
احنا من هذا المقترح ممدوح عليه معالي
الرئيس احنا من خلال هذا احنا نطالب
باعاده جدوله خطوط مربحه الى طيران الخليج
على اساس شعب البحرين يستفيد
وتسهل للعمليه وكذلك اقتصاديا على المستوى
الاقتصادي هم يستفيد تستفيد طيران الخليج
شكرا
احمد قراطه انتم موافق والله معارض
[موسيقى]
انا اللي قلت قبل
البحريني اشر لك ويقول لك احذف هذا
المستشار ليش البحرين